جنديرس من الحدود التركيه ومركز الزلزال
اضافه الى يعني ما قلته بان البنايات اصلا
غير صالحه للسكن كل ذلك ادى الى يعني
ارتفاع
فصيله القتلى في هذه البلده اضف الى ذلك
بان يعني فرق الانقاذ لم تتوجه في اليوم
الاول بشكل كافي الى جنديرس يعني تاخرت
حوالي 24 ساعه يعني تبدا العمل في بلده
جنديرس الاولويات في البدايه كانت سلقين
وسرمدا
والاتارب في ارياف ادلب الغربيه قبل
التوجه الى جنديرس ثم تسع نطاق البحث بعد
كثير من
الاستغاثات التي وصلت من الاهالي وايضا
بعد يعني الضجه الاعلاميه التي اثرتها هذه
المدينه اليوم كي يتركز فيها كل جهود
البحث لان حجم الدمار الكبير هناك ايضا
فريق اسباني يحمل معدات يقال بانها متطوره
وجيده تعمل مع فرق الدفاع المدني في هذه
البلده للوصول الى المباني المتبقيه هناك
84 مبنى مدمر في البدايه وصلوا الى 12
مبنى الان يصلون الى 35 مبدا ونطاق عمليات
البحث والانقاذ تتسع في هذه المدينه في
وقت تتضاءل فيه فرص العثور على اي ناجين
جدد انا قلت انا خلال العشرين ساعه
الماضيه لم يتم انتشال اي شخص على قيد
الحياه وانما ثلاثه جثث من هذه البلده